our lead national correspondent david
begno is also in boulder with the latest
on the investigation and what we are
learning about how the attack
happened david good morning
good morning the associated press
reports that the suspect's family told
police they think he's mentally ill
suffering from some type of delusion
he thought he was being followed or
chased
and that a relative of the gunman also
told police that she thinks she saw him
playing with what looked like a machine
gun
just a couple of days before the
massacre started here at the supermarket
behind me
people lying in the street guys the
shooting started in the parking lot
where according to the arrest warrant
the suspect shot an elderly man
multiple times he's inside the building
right now
the suspect then allegedly made his way
inside wearing tactical gear
and armed with a semi-automatic handgun
and a rifle
and he started firing on employees and
customers
my co-worker looked at me and i looked
at him and he says that's not
breaking glass that's an ar-15 i just
saw the dude hit the floor
daniel who did not want to share his
last name was shopping with his
co-worker
i started shooting in the store and we
started running to the store telling
everybody to follow us
[Music]
nearly 50 minutes after the massacre
began an
officer arrested the suspect who was
wearing only shorts
after he had apparently removed his
clothing inside the store
officers arrived on the scene within
minutes and immediately entered the
store
and engaged the suspect according to the
warrant the suspect ahmed alissa
bought an assault weapon less than a
week before the shooting he purchased it
on march 16th
the 21 year old was born in syria but he
grew up in the united states
his brother told the daily beast he
believes alyssa is mentally ill
he described him as paranoid and
anti-social
and he says he was bullied in high
school now police records indicate when
he was in high school back in 2018
alyssa was convicted of misdemeanor
assault after he punched another student
several times during math class
according to an incident report alyssa
claimed that he had been bullied by the
student for about a year
but more than two dozen witnesses in the
class told investigators
that the attack appeared unprovoked as
of this morning officials here in
boulder have not yet released a motive
behind the supermarket massacre are
going to do everything
in our power to make sure the suspect
has a thorough trial and we do a
thorough investigation
now this is interesting roughly four
years ago the city of boulder passed a
ban on assault weapons the intention was
they wanted to stop exactly what
happened here at the grocery store but
just
10 days ago a court ruled that the
ban was ineffective right they overruled
boulder's ban because the nra filed a
lawsuit
and the nra argued that colorado has a
state law which says
local cities like boulder cannot pass
their own
gun laws and the nra won
tony david thank you very much